it's 480 BC the Greek army led by King
Leonidas and 300 Spartans is facing a
Persian army a quarter of a million men
the Persian King Xerxes watched in
disbelief as 700 Greek troops warmed up
at the Valley Inn hence they lined up in
a phalanx formation phalanx the forest
of spirits
the commander would signal for the push
rear ranks pushing forward and pressing
their shields against the backs of the
men in front and you pushed against the
forces opposing you and literally tried
to shove them backwards and drive them
off the field they trained their whole
lives for this moment this phalanx was
18 men deep and 64 cross their shields
overlapped like the scales of a serpent
back virtually impenetrable
first three ranks lowered their spirits
and rolled forward towards the me
in contrast to the Greeks the Medes were
lightly armed they carried light
wickerwork shields and Spears
before they advanced the meat arches
fired a volley into the phallus
[Applause]
Layana dissent and more Greeks to
reinforce the phallus pressing their
weight into the backs of their fellow
troops volley after volley of arrows
filled the sky the Greek infantry at a
3-foot shield the shields were bronze
faced with maybe two inches of oak
underneath that so if you want to think
of that think of that as a kitchen
cutting board and how hard you can whack
a cutting board with a batteries when
you break it as the Greeks began to
tired
Liyana dissent in his Spartan warriors
they advanced in a phalanx formation as
the exhausted Greeks ran back as they
advanced they would be talking to each
other when inspiring each other
encouraging each other to advance while
these other people are coming advancing
towards you I mean as each step got
closer and closer the terror must have
been unbelievable
the highly-trained Spartans slaughtered
all in front
the Medes saw that their own weapons
were useless and in desperation began
grabbing at the Spartans fears mister
the zip us and the real butchery began
are you hungry
are you tired are you thirsty are you
wounded doesn't matter
you're a warrior and you fight the
confined space made it impossible for
the Persians to take advantage of their
superior numbers they could not pack
enough men into battle against this
unrelenting killing machine was all
hand-to-hand nobody shot anybody no
smart bombs came in if you are gonna
kill the enemy he was gonna be right in
your face and trying to kill you wave
after wave
Dirk sees warriors perished as they
tried to penetrate the Spartan shield
wall beyond this joke
Xerxes has plenty of men but no soldiers
but the Spartans took casualties as well
Spartans had a method for identifying
their dead many of whom were battered
beyond recognition they would take a
twig and put their mark at either end
and then break it in half half was kept
in a bowl behind the lines and the other
was worn around the wrist so there you
have the ancient equivalent of a dog tag
if the soldier survived he could reclaim
his twig after the battle if not the
dead didn't lost the be easily counted
as the battle moved into the second day
the Persians could make no headway they
were simply not prepared for this kind
of fighting far removed from the wide
open plains of the East where cavalry
cherries and light infantry that decide
the outcome
sitting on his hillside throne Xerxes
became more and more agitated jumping to
his feet every so often like a spectator
at a football game mr. cheese just said
hey you guys go out there and take that
pass kick these guys out of the way and
these lightly armed needs went up
against the heavily armed Greeks and the
heavily are in Greece kicked their butt
Xerxes decided to play his trump card
and send in the Immortals it might have
been hundreds of thousands of soldiers
in the battlefield but now the combat
was between two fighting elites ten
thousand Persian immortals against what
remained of 300 Spartans August 480 BC
the Spartans had held the pass at
Thermopylae for nearly a day and a half
Xerxes had failed to crack their defense
now he gambled everything by sending in
his own personal guard the immortal
they were a magnificent sight
[Applause]
they carried bows Spears and short
daggers
[Applause]
the bank after ranked of the elite shock
troops fell in the dust
[Applause]
the right arm versions couldn't
penetrate the Greek armor but the Greeks
could penetrate them at will and also
the Greeks were trained to fight at
close quarters and to come to grips at
close quarters nothing could shake the
Spartans Xerxes needed a miracle and it
came from an unexpected source
a Greek trader Ephialtes seeing a chance
to get rich quick crossed over to the
Persian camp
he told Xerxes about a pathway that
wound around the mountainside and came
out behind the Spartans
the name Ephialtes has entered the
modern Greek language it means nightmare
in modern Greek Ephialtes is today a
nightmare and a cover of darkness the
Persians filed up the track
and on the morning of day three emerged
behind the Spartans
leonov us have been outflanked
you knew this would be his last battle
to avoid unnecessary casualties
he sent the rest of the Greek army home
the Spartans would stand alone it must
have been an amazingly emotional moment
as men were walking out brave men
knowing they were going to live while
others were walking up to the front line
knowing that they were going to die
one of the Greeks had warned the
Persians have so many archers that their
arrows will blot out the Sun well said
the spark of DNA keys we will fight in
the shade
this was Spartan wit and when somebody
says something like that you laugh and
fear goes away
Leonidas was more somber he ordered his
men to breakfast saying tonight we shall
dine in Hades the battle recommenced
the Persians closed in from both sides
on the tiny band of Spartan survivors
with the Spartans with nothing to lose
[ __ ] like demons
the Persians suffered heavy losses then
Layana dispel his Spartan soldiers
rushed forward to save his body from
capture and mutilation fact that the
Greeks fought in the way they did to
preserve his body from the Persians at
the moment of final defeat again
symbolizes how important the position
the the status the role of the king the
leader actually was Xerxes now decided
to bring this battle to a quick end it's
right to fight soldier to soldier an
honorable tradition this Persian
ancestry but he could not break the
Spartans he had lost Hindley 10,000 men
including two of his own brothers
he decided to withdraw his troops he
would finish the Spartans off at a safe
distance with arrows
the spartans regarded the bow as a
weapon for cowards because it killed
from a distance thousands of arrows
rained down on the broken spartans until
not one was left standing
they were finished off by the weapons
they despised most
a furious Xerxes ordered his men to find
the body of Leonidas and once they found
it to cut off his head and stick it on a
pole the Spartan King had made him pay a
terrible price for victory at
Thermopylae
10,000 casualties was a drop in the
bucket from such a vast force but it was
a blow to Xerxes and the morale of his
army he was astonished that men would
fight for an ideal the ideal of freedom
Xerxes raced on through Thermopylae to
capture a fleet but its citizens and
army had already fled later that same
year 480 BC they took two ships and
defeated the Persians and a great sea
battle at Salamis Xerxes grand scheme
was in ruins
had the spartans not done their bid at
thermopylae then i think the whole war
effort the whole greet resistance would
have started to crumble for the greeks
it was destiny a Spartan King had died a
Persian King had been defeated just as
the Oracle had prophesied all kinds of
great civilizations are vanished that
left incredible monuments but the
Spartans left nothing but what they left
just by their actions that one day is
more indelible and is still living today
the people of Greece the courage and
heroism of Thermopylae had sent a
message of hope and pride the 300
Spartans would never be forgotten
a grateful Greece paid the poet's amah
notice to compose their epitaph
go tell the Spartans stranger passing by
and here obedient to their laws we lie
you